I've been called all sorts of nasty
things by the liberal press Tucker so I
tend to expect everything but I have to
admit being accused of genocide did take
me by surprise that seemed extreme even
for the fake news media and I think it
surprised a lot of lawyers as well The
Daily Beast and the Huffington Post and
rolling stone and a number of other
outlets all spread this lie about me
they just put words into my mouth that I
never said you heard exactly what I said
I said that for the good of these people
in particular so presumably I don't want
to murder them I talked about an
ideology in particular I'm not talking
about eradicating any human beings this
is libel this is actionable libel you
know the libel laws in the United States
have quite a high threshold to actually
Sue this meets that threshold I think
that unless the news editors at The
Daily Beast and rolling stone and
Huffington Post and all the rest unless
they're completely illiterate they lied
intentionally and I think their lawyers
called them and said change the headline
or you're going to get sued into
Oblivion